[Music]
we love the loud house so much that we
watched the show over and over again
just so we could see if we missed any
small details but way to tell you here
about the mystery that's only known to
the biggest loud house fans give this
video a thumbs up and hit that subscribe
button to never miss another loud house
video again now let's check out 10 small
details in the loud house only true fans
have noticed peanuts reference if you
watch some of our other videos on the
loud house you probably already know
this but there's a specific small detail
and one of the scenes only real fans of
the show managed to catch and you might
not even notice what is going on unless
you're a huge fan of peanuts in homes
pun the 26th episode of season one we
see Lloyd loud senior fixing the roof
antenna after he almost falls down the
roof the scene cuts to the girls
watching the TV and tearing set it's a
lot better now but have you noticed
what's actually playing on TV it's a
cartoon version of two characters that
seem to be leaning on a brick wall but
that same scene is actually the opening
scene to a Charlie Brown Christmas of
course small details have been changed
and overall the illustration of the
cartoon has to fit the loud house style
instead of the old-school illustration
but if you look at the details you'll
notice it's definitely a shout out to
peanut make sure you watch some of our
other videos to find other references to
peanuts on the show it turns out that
Chris Savino was a huge fan of hiding
Easter eggs and other pop culture
references into the loud house episodes
their parents 11 loud a leapin is a
special episode for anyone who's a real
fan of the show we're talking about fans
who noticed this tiny detail that was
pretty much overlooked by most you
probably notice that cartoon parents
often hide their faces they're only
shown from the waist down to make sure
the atmosphere still fits into the kids
world rather than adding adults into the
mix and destroying the magic it seems
like this was the plan for the rathaus
but for some unknown reason this plan
changed with the final episode of season
1 it's actually the first episode that
shows the parents faces and most people
didn't even notice it happens as the
loud family along with Clyde's family
and
the other neighbors sing a Christmas
carol which was written by Luna what's
even more strange is that after this
episode we constantly see the parents
faces and they actually play an
important part in most of the episodes
it's a small detail but anyone who's a
true fan will probably know that the
first season was mostly focused on the
kids the parents didn't become a part of
the story until their face reveal in the
second season do you think this show
would be different if the parents never
showed their faces let us know in the
comments
Lisa's education here's another small
detail no one really cares about unless
you're 100% invested in this show and if
you are we can't blame you because we're
sure you can tell by our videos that we
are to one of our favorite characters on
the show is Lisa she's incredibly smart
even though she still speaks with an
adorable list but it seems like her
super intelligence is causing several
inconsistencies in the storyline for
example we all know Lisa graduated from
college as a teacher in CoverGirl's the
fifteenth episode of season 1 but in one
of the season 2 episodes called making
the grade Lisa is still in kindergarten
of course she finds it too easy and gets
transferred to Lincoln's class but
there's no explanation why that happened
in the first place considering she
should already be attending university
by season 2 have you noticed this detail
about Lisa before we want to hear from
all true fans of the show what's your
explanation behind it we have a feeling
this is just a simple continuity error
by the creative team but you can blame
them when you're designing a story for
11 unique characters with strong and
over-exaggerated personalities you might
find yourself struggling to remember
every single thing about them speaking
of the team behind the loud house do you
know what they actually look like he'll
be surprised to learn that you do know
even if you think you don't know it the
loud house staff here's another Easter
Egg we bet you never noticed in the loud
house most animators leave their mark on
a cartoon they work on especially if
it's a popular cartoon we bet you never
paid attention to the random people you
see in the loud house you know the ones
that are a part of the background and
can usually be found cheering at a game
or in a crowd no one pays attention to
but a huge fan managed to spot everyone
who works for the loud house in a single
scene of the cartoon you can
the same scene in poor bros about to
rock when Luna stands in line to go to
the concert pay close attention to the
actual line these are the people that
work behind the scenes on the show and
the bearded guy with the purple sweater
is actually Chris Savino you can also
see editors and other animators even the
writer Karla Sokka Shropshire can be
spotted on the far right pretty
impressive right to be fair if we worked
on a show like the loud house we'd also
make sure there's a character that
represents us somewhere and their
creators always like to put Easter eggs
like these in their work but we bet most
fans never even knew about this one
Lisa's clothes now this small detail is
very easy to miss and to be honest we
didn't pay a lot of attention to it the
first time around let's take it back to
the very first episode in the series
that started the loud house craze in
left in the dark we get introduced to
the family and learn all about the loud
siblings including their personalities
we always mentioned that Lisa's our
favorites we adore her cute list but we
love her clothing even more her sweater
looks so comfortable but did you know
that it didn't always look that color go
back to the first episode and compare
the color of her sweaters you'll notice
that her sweater has a different color
it's a much brighter green that's never
seen again after instead the color turns
into a much less vivid green that fits
in with the background and the rest of
the colors around her we're not sure if
this was a strategic move to make sure
the color is easily visible without
gathering too much attention or if it's
just a simple mistake by the animators
but once you see it you can never unsee
it again which color do you prefer we
have to be honest
we love the vivid green rather than the
lime-green color it's just so cute dirty
face it's hard to choose a favorite in
the loud house but apart from Lisa we
also really love Lana it's hard to
believe she has a twin sister who's the
complete opposite of her rowdy tomboy
character and to be completely honest we
like Lana just a little bit more she
always gets herself in some kind of mess
and it's very entertaining to watch in a
long came a sister Lincoln brings home a
tarantula and makes sure he hides it
from Lenny who's afraid of spiders after
hiding the tarantula he realized he's
lost it and panics the twins confront
him on what's going on and gets
suspicious especially
Lincoln tries to get out of it by saying
Lana is cute they both know there's no
way he'd ever say that if you pay
attention to the scene you'll notice
that Lana's face is really dirty
she has dirt everywhere but in the very
next scene from another angle she's
suddenly clean again unless you pay
close attention to the show and know
every small detail this scene is very
easy to miss make sure to watch our
videos if you want to know more about
animation mistakes in the show it turns
out there are quite a few of them like
our next mistake which shows Clyde in a
completely different light
Clyde's chip tooth the loud house also
introduces us to some of the characters
with some of the most progressive
cartoon families ever and Clyde is
definitely one of those characters
although the show has been banned in
some countries because it Clyde's dads
we think the entire family is pretty
adorable but what's even more adorable
is Clyde and Lincoln's friendship the
two BFFs spend a lot of time together
and we love seeing Clyde completely melt
over Laurie he cannot be himself when
he's around her but what's even more
adorable about Clyde are his buck teeth
which are shown in almost every episode
well except in get the message where
they mistakenly get a different shape
when Lincoln realizes his gaming glasses
were stamped on he automatically blames
Laurie as she was the last person to
enter the bathroom which is where he
left them after telling Clyde his best
friend gets totally overwhelmed that the
love of his life stucked her foot on
those glasses but if you pay attention
to his teeth during the scenes in
Lincoln's room you'll notice this is the
only time you'll ever see Clyde with a
chipped tooth we have no idea whether
this was a mistake or if you just
somehow managed to chip his tooth just
for that scene the most important thing
is that he still is adorable as ever the
show definitely wouldn't be the same
without him Laurie's tongue but it's not
just a tooth that went missing in the
loud house we also spotted this
incredibly small detail that requires
you to pause your loud house episode at
the precise time otherwise who
completely miss it and it happened in
the same episode in the first scene we
see Lincoln passionately dancing to his
weird zombie VR game and for some reason
he manages to totally leave the living
room and go upstairs
he accidentally finds himself in
Laurie's room who's of course visibly
unhappy Laurie doesn't like it when her
younger siblings go into her room
and she says that loud and clear well
she actually yells it at Lincoln but pay
attention to her tongue in that scene
he'll notice that at some point it loses
its outline and just looks like a weird
stem and colored dot coming from her
mouth it's one of those small details
we've never expect anyone to see once
you go deeper into the loud house
episodes and really pay attention to the
animation you're seeing you'll be able
to notice more and more details that
aren't always there or some that go
missing in certain scenes maybe who
knows maybe the animators wanted us to
notice these things just so we could
talk about the loud house as much as we
do sounds pretty clever right Lincoln
strength we've already spoken about how
it's probably really hard to continue
with the storyline of so many characters
and remember exactly what someone said
or did in previous episodes we bet there
are a lot more cases like this so do
make sure to tell us in the comments if
you ever spot a continuity error but
here's another one Lincoln doesn't look
like he's particularly strong especially
since he doesn't really do sports or
anything that would make us see his
muscles so in link or swim there's no
wonder that he wasn't able to carry
Lynne on his shoulders after she jumps
on him but in its a loud loud loud loud
house we see him holding Lynne after the
to get in a fight if he isn't able to
pick up Lynne because his muscles are
weak she definitely wouldn't be able to
hold Lynne after a fight especially
since it seems like these siblings were
fighting quite a lot that day we're
really not sure how to feel about
Lincoln's strength
he looks strong when he needs to but
he's not strong when we're supposed to
laugh at the scene although to be honest
Lynne jumping on him would make him
pretty weak and unable to hold her and
to be fair he did a really good job at
trying a lost episode if you're a true
fan of the show you probably know
everything about it including things
that people who only watch the episode
Stone while this is definitely not a
small detail it's a fact that's known
among the loud house fans and no one
seems to know whether this is just fan
fiction or reality but whatever it is
it's definitely still talked about one
Wikia user claims they stumbled on a
website which featured a bunch of
unedited things that related to TV shows
and movies one of them was the loud
house they described that they found a
lost episode called enough is enough
where Lincoln come
we loses his mind and finally has enough
of living with his ten sisters this
story is pretty creepy but it definitely
seemed to have convinced a lot of fans
the writer even mentioned they couldn't
believe a show like the loud house would
even Beach or something so gruesome as
that lost episode of course we all know
that you should always take things like
that with a grain of salt especially
since there's no proof whatsoever we
can't imagine Lincoln turning the loud
house into a four story but this mystery
scene is definitely still popular among
true fans of the show what do you think
is it real or fake and that's it for our
video make sure to hit that like button
and subscribe to our Channel
see you next time
[Music]